[Music]
so
spirit as the essence that is
self-consciousness or the self-conscious
being that
is all truth and knows all reality as
its own self
is to begin with only its notion
in contrast to the actuality which it
gives itself
in the movement of its consciousness and
this
notion is as contrasted with the
daylight of this explicit development
the night of its essence as contrasted
with the outer existence
of its moments as independent shapes it
is the creative
secret of its birth this secret has its
revelation
within itself for the existence of its
moments has its necessity in this notion
because this notion is self-knowing
spirit and therefore
has in its essence the moment of being
consciousness
and of presenting itself objectively
this is the pure eye which in its
externalization has within itself as
universal object
the certainty of its own self or in
other words
this object is for the eye the
penetration of all thought
and all reality
with paragraph 685 we now are going to
approach one of the determinate
shapes of consciousness one of the
gestalton
that we were talking so much in the
previous paragraphs
both in the general introduction to the
religion section right
there's religion and such and then it
takes all these particular
shapes in particular religions and then
in the previous paragraph
684 that massive introduction to natural
religion hegel said
there's all these determinate aspects
and each shape
focuses on on one of them and so that's
what we're actually
getting to see more or less in its
native habitat here
in this paragraph and the three
paragraphs that
follow it i do have to say something
about the particular religion that hegel
has
in mind here and the place to start
is with the translation that miller has
god
as light when you look at what the
german is
you know dust licks vs and it's not
exactly god is light
it's rather essence as light or the
essence
that is light but we are talking about
a configuration of the divine so
it does make sense to use the term god
and as it as it happens
hegel does have in mind a particular
we can call it world religion a religion
that
at one time had a much more
significant following than it than it
did
in his time than it does in the present
and that
is the religion of zoroastrianism
you know focused on the uh
living out a life that is in accordance
with the truth the asha
as opposed to the drug and engaged with
a
or you know there's other names for it
as well and there's also an
evil principle which could be called
anger my new
araman there's there's different names
for it hegel's not going to actually use
any
of those here but this is what is going
on because
as we find out in when hegel does
lectures later on his lectures on the
philosophy of religion a course which he
repeated
more than once actually a number of
times
[Music]
this is the religion of light is the
religion of zoroaster
zoroastrianism he calls it the religion
of the parsees
which is technically half correct right
because the parsees are zoestrians who
fled iran
and wanted up settling in india
and were called parsis after you know
persians
and but there are there are also you
know worshippers in other places as well
so all of that's kind of interesting
background
why the light why is that so important
and why is hegel associating
zoroastrianism with light again if we if
we go to the
lectures on the philosophy of religion
what we do find is that hegel is making
a good attempt
to wrap his head around this religion
but he's also got it within his sequence
of of religions interestingly it's not
the first one that he treats in talking
about natural religion
it's actually the fourth but here he
places it
first there's clearly some development
in his ideas and understanding as he
goes along
he doesn't have a you know really solid
view of it as is possible in the present
for westerners but um you know it's it's
pretty
decent at least and we can see some
elements
of zoroastrianism showing up i want to
remind you as well before we jump into
this that
just in the last paragraph hegel told us
that there's all these different aspects
in religion there's higher and lower
aspects
but some religions are going to take the
lower
aspects and make them higher and not
really develop
the higher aspects so the way that
hegel views zoroastrianism here it's
it's one of those
right all of the natural religions are
are really doing that even when we get a
little bit later on
into the religion of the artificer that
it's still not going to be quite the
same as what's coming later
so he tells us spirit is the essence the
vasen
that is self-consciousness or the
self-conscious
being that now here's where we get some
interesting translation well i'm going
to run through the text
that is all truth and knows all reality
as its own self
is to begin with only its notion in
contrast to the actuality which it gives
itself in the
movement of its consciousness so very
typical hegelian language there
very metaphysical what what's actually
going on here
before we jump into the what's going on
i have to point out
something that when you go to the german
text you see that what miller is
translating as
actuality is in fact the german term
reality right which is a
you know sort of germanization of the
the latin term
realitas and what's corresponding to
that usually virklikeit
right and what he's tr what miller has
translated in this passage
as reality is
verclickit so vehicle kite is reality
uh real reality is actuality
it almost would have been better if he
would have just said you know reality
reality uh vehicle kite actuality
uh it's not that big of a deal but but
it might be
helpful for for some so
he tells us that um this this you know
the self-conscious being
that is all truth this is a term he's
going to use several times
in here and he's going to couple it with
actuality or reality if we we
want to use either of these terms so it
knows all reality as its own self
this is you know uh what he's been
talking about for for quite a long time
this is not actually going to be the
phenomenological subject but this is the
subject of god you could say
so self-conscious spirit now he says
it it is to begin with only its notion
and once again
only its notion only the notion in the
the raw
bare sense in contrast to the actuality
the reality which it gives itself now
that's
that's another interesting term right
and hegel does use the word gabe in
there
to give to provide
to show to itself we could even say in
terms of the s
gift right it's there right so
spirit is showing itself to itself
in what it becomes
how it develops and
he goes on and he says um
[Music]
which gives itself in the movement the
vague
right it what it's transiting of its
consciousness bovus
then he goes on and he tells us a little
bit more about this notion
he says this notion is as contrasted
gagan right with the daylight
actually just togg so but that's
daylight is fine right
the the daylight of this explicit
development explicit development
is a little bit of a play on asm that
means where you
you're saying a little bit more than you
need to and faltering it just means
unfolding right so
yes explicit development becoming
explicit i mean
explicit is very close to unfaltering
because
it's coming from the latin terms of uh
you know
unfolding as well so
that's not bad explicit development
they both kind of go along with that so
what the what the religion is doing and
what the
concept of god is doing in this is our
explicit development so the notion
is contrasted as the night of its
essence
he says as contrasted with the outer
existence of its
moments as independent shapes so we have
independent shapes
on this side you know
really a whole set of independent shapes
in terms of beings
and then we have a secret that it's
coming out of
gaimnes you can say mystery if you like
um and that that secret is going to
like he says this is a creative secret
of its birth
and then the secret he says this is
really interesting habits has its
revelation open bong right
within itself so
the secret what is being hidden away
uh what is not visible opens itself out
reveals itself to us very
phenomenological language in this isn't
there
so he says it has its revelation within
itself for the existence
of its moments has its necessity in this
in this notion because this notion is
self-knowing spirit and therefore has
in its essence the moment of being
consciousness
and presenting itself objectively
the objectively there is it's presenting
itself as an object
for itself so the
reality that's being you know or the
actuality that's being
produced here that it's giving to itself
is how
it is figuring itself to itself
right this is not something really all
that new
with with hegel we've seen this happen
over and over again now we're seeing it
happen in terms of religion
and so he says that this is the pure eye
again something we've seen before
which in its externalization has within
itself
as universal object
the certainty of its own self now that's
kind of a strange thing to say isn't it
it has as its object itself it's you
know scrutinizing its own self it's it's
relating itself to itself
but what it has is is its universal
object
is the certainty give his height of its
own self
so it can be secure and this is you know
a beginning point really
uh when we begin with certainty and then
he says or in other words this object
is for the eye and we come back again to
this the penetration
of all thought and all reality
so the penetration of that
is being able to get to the bottom of it
all thoughts including our thought but
also the thought of god
and all all reality all
actuality so this is priming us to move
into the next paragraph you notice
there's not
that much actually happening as such in
this
other than what we've got a secret and
that secret you know is is
showing itself revealing itself to
itself
through how it unfolds
in the immediate first direction of
self-knowing absolute spirit its
shape has the determination which
belongs to immediate consciousness or
to sense certainty spirit beholds itself
in the form of being
though not of the non-spiritual being
that is filled with the contingent
determinations
of sensation the being that belongs to
sense certainty
on the contrary it is being that is
filled with
spirit it also includes the form which
appeared in immediate self-consciousness
the form of lord
and master over against the
self-consciousness
that retreats from its object this being
which is filled with the notion of
spirit is then the shape of the simple
relation of spirit to itself
or is the shape of shapelessness
in virtue of this determination this
shape
is the pure all-embracing and
all-pervading essential light of sunrise
which preserves itself in its formless
substantiality
its otherness is the equally simple
negative
darkness the movements of its own
externalization
its creations in the unresisting element
of its otherness are torrents of light
in their simplicity they are at the same
time the genesis of its being for
self and the return from the existence
of its moments
streams of fire destructive of all
structured form
the moment of difference which it gives
itself does
it is true proliferate unchecked in the
substance of existence
and shapes itself to the forms of nature
yet the essential simplicity of its
thought moves aimlessly about
it without stability or intelligence
enlarges its bounds to the measureless
and its beauty heightened to splendor is
dissolved in its
sublimity
paragraph 686 is the
longest one in this short section and
it's arguably the the one in which the
most
determinate stuff is happening although
maybe the last paragraph in it there's
also
something worth pointing out in that
respect as well
and so hegel is telling us more about
what he sees
happening in this religion of of light
corresponding to zoroastrianism and he
tells us in the
immediate first direction enzyme right
splitting into
two of self-knowing absolute spirit its
shape its gestalt has the determination
which belongs to immediate consciousness
or to
sense certainty so it almost sounds like
we're going back to
the very beginning of the work
and he tells us we've got you know sense
certainty
happening here and how is this the case
well it is immediate right and we're
beginning with something
really seemingly basic he goes on and he
says
spirit beholds itself in the form
of being through this you know
sense certainty or immediate
consciousness um
and then he clarifies something really
important here so this is not
not as he calls it non-spiritual being
non-geistiga
that was the object of sense certainty
and i think back to sensory right we so
we see a tree
okay a tree could be an object of
worship for some people but it can also
just be
you know the stuff i'm seeing in front
of my face and i look around it
and eventually we get to the thing and
it's attributes okay there is a
uh you know spiritual aspect to that but
part of what was going on in the whole
consciousness section was realizing
that i as the perceiving subject
i was putting all this stuff out into
the world
and here what we're seeing is no there's
there's something that is being grasped
as immediate but as essential
as divine so he tells us that
it is being that is filled with spirit
and he also had something else he says
it also includes the form which appeared
in immediate self-consciousness
the form of lord and master now lord and
masters
just two different ways of translating
the same one single word
hair right the the master the lord
in the master slave dialectic uh and you
know
you could say running through the rest
of
that whole section of self-consciousness
you know things are still in the shadow
of the lord
as we're going through the the things
that follow after the master slave
dialectic
and so he tells us you know the form of
lord and master
over against the self-consciousness that
retreats from its object and
we could probably also read in there
that
you know the lord is also filled with
spirit or the lord is spirit
right and we're retreating from it what
is the lord that we're talking about
here
well if it's zoroastrianism uh a mazda
the bounteest the wise lord
right the good lord the highest
of the uh you know the beings that that
are
uh the one who created the the universe
along with
you know perhaps other beings the
absolutely good spirit and
you know it's interesting i mean if you
think about this hegel's not really
i think picking up on this himself but
within zoroastrianism ahura mazda is a
spirit he's not a not a body
um and so hegel goes out and he says
this being which is filled with the
notion of spirit
is then the shape of the simple relation
of spirit to itself
and here's where he says something
really kind of interesting the shape
of shapelessness so shape here is
gestalt right
the gestalt the gestalt losing
the lack of having form so the form
of formlessness the form of
transcending form the form of going
beyond form
right this is a possibility it seems
inherent
in the entire array of forms that there
could be a form
that is not fixed is not determined but
is rather
formless so that's you know that's quite
important
what could that be like well here's
where he talks about light
he goes on and he says that the the
shape of shapelessness right form of
formlessness in virtue of this
determination
what determination uh the shapelessness
the shape
is the pure all-embracing
and all pervading something
essential light right leaked vase
what we were talking about here in this
entire section this is this is the god
uh god as light is the leaked vason so
the essential light is the
rising of the sun i mean it doesn't
actually say sunrise
it's it's um just talking about the you
know the east but we could read that in
there if we want to
the essential light of sunrise which
preserves itself
in its formless substantiality you know
it the the notion of the sun as being
central is not
unique in any way to zoroastrianism uh
we see this in many religions we also
see this in philosophies think about
the role that the sun plays in allowing
us to
conceptualize the form of the good in
plato's republic
right so there's there's really
something there about the sun it for for
ancient people it's the brightest light
you're going to see
um you know barring some sort of
horrible natural catastrophe
so and it gives light to everything and
it doesn't you know there are shadows of
course
uh but shadows are cast because of
sunlight
now here's something quite interesting
that hegel is going to point out
so this is a vason right this is an
essence
this is a being and then he goes on and
he says
it's otherness what's the otherness to
what the the light
is the equally simple negative darkness
uh finsterness right darkness gloom
you know whatever we want to call it
it's it's it's an
opposite to light and there's really
nothing
interesting there it's not an essence of
itself
right it's it's pretty simple form of
negation
and he goes on and he says the moment
the movements of its own externalization
its creations and the unrest resisting
elements of its otherness
now what what are we talking about here
the god of light
are torrents of light streams of light
in their simplicity they are at the same
time
the genesis of its being for self uh the
term there is actually frusivirdon right
so it's it's becoming for itself is
another way
of translating that um
and their simplicity they are that and
the return from the existence of its
moments
streams of fire destructive of all
structured form destructive of
of anything being fixed
now at the same time as we saw or
said a little bit earlier uhura mazda is
the
creator and so there is
a you know substance of existence a
dozen
um actually substance to design right
and this leads us to having forms and he
uses the word
form in there right not not gestalt
forms of
nature so the natural world
it shapes itself into that but he says
the essential simplicity of its thought
what's thought the thought of the light
god moves aimlessly about it without
stability or intelligence
enlarges its bounds to the measureless
and its beauty heightened
splendor is dissolved in its sublimity
so what is hegel saying here well this
is really great
that something worth worshipping in in
some respect
light you know the sun ahura mazda
a god who bats away or pushes away the
darkness
but there's something for hegel
fundamentally
lacking here it's all very um
abstract it could it could really extend
itself
to anything he actually says something
kind of like this in the
as i mentioned before he's got a
discussion of the zoroastrian religion
in his lectures on the history or the
the philosophy of religion and he tells
us that you know
the lord is good but good doesn't really
mean anything
so what we're missing here is any sort
of
real determinacy and
you know right or wrong hegel is
ascribing that to this this kind or this
stage
of religion
the content developed by this pure being
or the activity of its perceiving
is therefore an essence-less biplay in
this substance which merely ascends
without descending into its depths
to become a subject and through the self
to consolidate
its distinct moments the determinations
of this substance are only attributes
which do not attain to self-subsistence
but remain merely names of the many
named
one this one is clothed with the
manifold powers of existence
and with the shapes of reality as with
an adornment that lacks a self they are
merely messengers having no will of
their own
messengers of its might visions of its
glory
voices in its praise
paragraph 687 is is very short and also
relatively straightforward
it helps have a little bit of background
knowledge about
zoroastrianism to understand what hegel
is getting at in in some of the things
that he's saying
in it particularly about these
attributes and then
and then messengers but you could
probably read it without any great
knowledge of
of that particular religion and so he
tells us that
the content developed by this pure being
what is the pure being the light essence
god ahara mazda right
or the activity of its perceiving and
now notice he uses the term perceiving
there
uh just the in a previous paragraph he
talked about sense certainty
and sense certainty is the very first
you know part of consciousness and then
we have perception
var nemo so we're making some some
progress
through that he tells us that
it's an essenceless byplay
in this substance which merely ascends
now what's wrong with ascending hegel is
thinking that you need to
descend into something
that is going to be you could say
challenging or requiring determinacy or
some sort of process
without descending into its depth to
become a subject
and through the self to consolidate
its distinct moments right so
there's something missing in development
here
there's there's a foregoing and
a jumping ahead and maintaining a kind
of immediacy
or if you like to use the pat the
concept that you brought in formlessness
right a lack of of gestalt and so he
talks about the
divine substance here and that
is the bounteous lord or her mazda
if this is indeed supposed to be
zoroastrianism
so he tells us that the determinations
the ways in which this substance
is determined what we can know about it
right our
only attributes and interestingly he
uses
atabuta here uh again taking it
just directly from the latin it seems
which do not attain to self-subsistence
but remain merely names of a many named
one
so what are we talking about there the
attributes
of god are merely names
merely titles merely ways we can talk
about god
a god that is one but has many names
and the attributes being just names
and lacking any self-subsistence or
any development means that they again
they become kind of arbitrary
we can pick any one that we want and it
doesn't really matter we could we could
you know line them up in worship in some
sort of litany
and a litany is a whole listing of of
essentially epithets or titles
it could also include you know
particular prayers please do this please
do this please do this
but it could also just be a listing of
all these names
and some litanies you know when you
don't know what the names are supposed
to signify
they're just you know just just a list
of
words in a way they're not quite names
because they're not naming anything
they're just
syllables and hegel is saying that this
is this is a problem with this religion
of of light and he says this one
is clothed with the manifold powers of
existence and with the shapes of reality
as with a an adornment that lacks a self
it didn't again didn't descend to the
depths so it doesn't get that
itself there merely and here's where he
says something really interesting
they're merely
messengers now messengers have a kind of
agency don't they aren't they
beings on their own all of these
determinations that we have they're
merely
messengers bolton right and hagel tells
us no that's
they don't really have any
self-subsistence they're really just
you know reflections of the divine
substance and this reflects certain
ways of understanding zoastrianism
for example when all of the yazitas are
the beings worthy of worship
or the spentas the divine
heptad which you can call a certain kind
of angel
are basically looked as just emanations
of the divine
substance right hegel talks about it
that way they have no will
right eigen is villains uh and
they're deprived of their own will
right and all they can do is communicate
what the divine substance has power or
might
mocked visions of its glory on showing
insider
herely kite is glory it's also the lord
and then
voices in its praise stimuns and his
prizes
um so if in this interpretation at least
of zoroastrianism
all of the uh meshes pentas
or the yazatsas all of those divine
beings that are in a wake
sort of like lowercase g gods they're
just reflections of the divine substance
and
and they don't really do anything in
this this scheme
however this reeling unconstrained life
must determine itself as being
for self and endow its vanishing shapes
within an enduring
subsistence the immediate being
in which it stands in antithesis to its
consciousness
is itself the negative power which
dissolves its distinctions
it is thus in truth the self and spirit
therefore
passes on to know itself in the form of
self
pure light disperses its unitary nature
into an infinity of forms and offers
itself
up as a sacrifice to being for self
so that from its substance the
individual
may take an enduring existence for
itself
paragraph 688 is really a transitional
paragraph it's not
actually telling us anymore about this
this particular stage of religion that
we began our study
of natural religion with god is light or
the you know the light essence uh
associated with zoroastrianism
for hegel instead he's he's preparing us
for the transition into the discussion
of
plant and animal as ways of
understanding
the religious object or god and so
what's happening here in paragraph 688
is really not developing further any of
the stuff that's been happening in the
previous paragraphs in terms of the
religion but it is
taking some of the motifs some of the
themes and saying
all right let's say that instead of
as in paragraph 687
instead of engaging in this merely
ascending without descending into its
steps
what if it does that and so he says this
reeling unconstrained
life so that's one way of understanding
it life
which is spirit which is also pure light
right must determine itself as being for
self now usually when we think about
being for self we're thinking about a
relation
to the self that's not exactly what's
going to be happening here
there's going to be a sacrifice
of its own being happening
and the this life having being for
self life with a capital l means that it
gives to lives to individual lives
living
things something of itself
and loses something in the process so it
tells us that it
must determine itself as being for
herself and thereby endow
its vanishing fish shapes gestalten
with an enduring substance subsistence
of a stay-in
right a remaining in place
so he tells us the immediate being in
which it stands in antithesis to its
consciousness is the negative power
which dissolves its its distinctions
that's not particularly helpful to know
except that the distinctions are you
know being dissolved into what into life
but then
we're finding new distinctions happening
so he says
it is thus in truth the self which is
what we're
looking for and spirit passes on to know
itself
in the form of self so what is religion
spirit knowing itself here
the spirit that's knowing itself is
going to know itself
through the vanishing shapes or as he
calls it a little bit later
an infinity of forms pure light
disperses its unitary nature into an
infinity
forms and notice these are not forms of
light these are
robust plant and animal
forms living things life
takes the form of life life life life
life
you know on to infinity
uppercase l life lowercase l
lives but not in the plural a whole
bunch of individuals
so he calls this um pure light offers
itself up
as a sacrifice to being for
self an upper in german right a
sacrifice
so that from its substance the
individual may take an enduring
existence
for itself and what is the individual at
this point we're not yet like the
individual the human being we're going
to get there very quickly
when we get to the artificer but we're
going to have the individual
as the planter animal
in the next section and we could also
say as the religious believer
associating himself with that so we take
god in a certain respect as light at
least
off the scene and now we turn to this
infinity
of tangible forms that we can
say maybe in some respect are god or
shapes of god
you